m
bonjour à tous bienvenue devant le
théâtre départementale pour le taux
total un festival de jeunes publics
et avec nous bonjour mesdames bonjour
alors la compagnie tetra dans ces ongs
donc un groupe une compagnie est ce que
vous pourriez commencer par vous
présenter tout simplement moi je vais
parler deux ongs du coup bassong et
c'est un groupe qui qui existe depuis 20
ans maintenant et qui fait de la musique
on va dire sans étiquette à des gens
qu'on aime bien maillé mélanger musique
électro rock voilà avec des paroles en
créole en français en anglais
je viens du camp de satan des vainqueurs
on m'a dit méthodes identiques toi qui
vas faire là mes chances
et puis à la compagnie de tetra danse
avec valérie bonjour alors la compagnie
tetra danse est installé à la réunion
depuis 25 ans presque en jeu c'est pas
quelque chose comme ça et aussi on fait
une danse assez on va dire qui change
tout le temps
voilà
et
est-ce qu'on peut changer les codes avec
les enfants est ce que justement on peut
tout mallet comme tu viens de le dire on
est parti du principe que voilà que le
concert millimétré ou voilà on a
attention intro complet un couple et
deux refrains etc
on voulait balayer un petit peu ça déjà
qu'on émet un petit peu l'impro avant
avec song et qu'on se laisser des
petites fenêtres la sai on est partis
encore plus loin on va vous demander
bah voilà que vous exprimez de taper
dans les mains de chants tibétains
allez-y c'est votre fête avec nous ok
mais c'est un duo géant night avec les
spectateurs vous leur dites au début
faites ce que vous voulez c'est quand
même fait pas peur de baignoires de quoi
non non non le l'enfant va voilà
l'enfant de ne demande que ça de
s'exprimer de partir de ce lâcher donc
donc on est tout le temps là alors dire
au contraire que ce sont les parents et
moi en tant que parent je suis pas on a
tendance à le redire mais chut méharée
arrêt de faire ci fais pas ça machin les
instits pareil
voilà c'est hiller folle à la récré quoi
une grande bouffée d'air frais
donc donc oui c'est tout à fait possible
de casser les codes et on danse aussi
énormément
ouais et puis moi je vais bientôt
grand-mère ça ne saurait tarder donc
maintenant j'ai plus besoin de les
éduquer je peux juste leur demander de
le why mais les petits comme les
grands je dirai tout comme les grands
faits les petits faux sont plus faciles
à amuser que les grands quand même hein
ils ont cette capacité là oui à de la
danse c'est quand même quelque chose que
tous les enfants m si on les laisse
s'amuser avec
et justement est ce que ça leur fait du
bien pas moi j'espère j'espère que ça
leur fait du bien et que les adultes en
auront envie de se faire du bien aussi
que ce temps pense complètement je crois
que c'est c'est encore quelque chose
qu'il faut qu'il faut dire et redire
parce que là on a on a l'expérience du
spectacle convient de faire ou il ya
tout de même des adultes qui alors qu'on
demande justement de lâcher prise
complètement et de voilà de se laisser
vivre de se laisser aller crier danser
bouger il ya quand même des adultes qui
trouve le moyen de calmer vous un petit
peu là parce que ça dépasse certaines
bornes de certaines limites et et
pourquoi se mettre des limites au final
fin ça va il va pas y avoir de souci
particulier on est juste là pour
partager un moment musical et dansant
avec eux il n'y a pas de problème et oui
je crois que c'est un c'est une sorte de
devoir de pour les artistes de dire à un
moment donné ben voilà arrêtons un petit
peu de toujours se contrôler et se
maîtriser enfin ça ça fait du bien de se
lâcher c'est vraiment bon pour la santé
on va finir par ça qu'est ce que vous
pensez de ce lieu de ce festival en mots
bas venez un arrêté de regarder la télé
puis venez voir on s'éclate pas mal ici
n'ont pas carrément c'est la grande
scène comme ça c'est c'est génial tout
cas merci beaucoup merci d'avoir tenu
sous le soleil vous avez compris le
message venez pousser ses portes
vas-y pas besoin de pousser elles sont
grandes ouvertes pour ce tout au total à
bientôt sur des recettes 4 tv